نعم هذه هي الروايه الرسميه او ما يقوله
وزير الداخليه لكن مشاهداتنا على الارض
كنا نشاهد شبان عاديين وخصوصا من شريحه
الطلاب هم الذين كانوا يقومون باعمال
الشغب هذه وهي في العموم لم تكن تستهدف
متاجر او محل معينه انما كانت هناك عمليات
احراق للقمامه المتكدسه في الشوارع هؤلاء
الطلاب هم لديهم الان حراكهم الخاص يقومون
بتنظيم التظاهرات خصوصا ليلا ويقومون
بعمليات احراق القمامه في الشوارع لتاخير
عناصر الشرطه التي تلاحقهم في كل
الشوارعهم ارهقوا الشرطه بشكل كبير لكن
ايضا هناك عدد من العناصر العنيفه من شبان
اليسار وهؤلاء يعرفون باسم الكتله السوداء
او البلاك بلوك هؤلاء يقومون ايضا
باستهداف خصوصا المصارف وشركات التامين
يقومون باستهداف واجهتها الزجاجيه لانهم
يقولون انها مسؤوله عن معاناتهم عن
معاناتهم في فرنسا وهؤلاء يمثلون راس
المال لذلك هم يقومون باستهدافها لكن حتى
الان الموكب الفارسي يسير بهدوء وهؤلاء
ايضا لم نراهم حتى الان الشبان الذين تحدث
عنهم وزير الداخلي اعدادهم قليله جدا حتى
الان